Film Courage: What's the difference between
the main character's wound and flaw?
Jen Grisanti, Speaker/Story/Career
Consultant, Author: They're interconnected,
they're the wound and the flaw
is interconnected. Something that
I recognize the story was the flaw is the
story of the wound and with that recognition I
saw how strategy wise a lot of stories are
starting with the flaw in its shining glory
the value in starting with the flaw is that you
are curious about the wound you don't have the
answer to what the wound is but you are curious
why is the character the way they are and then by
the climax we're getting a fuller view of the
wound so the difference is the wound is what
happens to the character that creates the void the
flaw is how we see it come out how the character
is escaping the wound through distraction
through destructive behavior with the flaw
right because if I think back to Emily The
Criminal she talked about living with her
grandmother yes so it hints like something she
wasn't raised by her parents yes so we knew
right yes so we don't totally know yes but we're
wondering why did she have these series of events
that happened and then I think it doesn't come out
right away so again your it keeps you hooked it's
the puzzle and knowing how to strategize the
puzzle is everything and and writers need to
recognize that it's all a journey the same thing
like when you think about the transformation with
falling in love how when we first fall in love
we don't know enough about romantic love to know
how to be to know exactly what and we're in this
continuous learning process and and it is the same
thing with the idea of this transformation where
we are you don't just know what to do with story
you don't just know oh this is how I'm going
to break it up and this is what the strategy
is the more that you study story the more that
you live story the more that you feel stored
worry your mind starts to see it in a depth that
you never knew was possible until you get there
and what's great is when you talk about falling in
love so many characters I'm just thinking back to
like swingers or any Christmas movie where it's
like someone's been jilted or they've been quote
unquote abandoned no one's calling yes and in
obsessing over that person they then meet someone
new yes who then later on it pays off where that
abandoner calls and they don't need them anymore
exactly interesting that's exactly right it is
all in the transformation and when we look at
our life and like in my own personal arc I look
at when I went through two defining moments that
sold my book storyline finding gold in your life
story and change your story change your life it
had to do with a long relationship that ended
in a short marriage early on in life and then
a career trajectory that was interrupted and in
looking at if those two moments hadn't happened
I wouldn't have found what I view as the love of
my life for the last nine years I wouldn't have
met him unless those two negative things happened
in my life so I think the the object of story is
to teach people when bad things happen there is
a greater purpose as it links to the healing of
the earlier wound and as it links to the overall
growth in the life process and because so many
of us in life when we're in the heat of our “All
Is Lost” moments aren't ready for that awareness
story is continuously making us conscious of
that awareness and do you think that in a good
story that that always lost moment has to then
resurface slated on down the line once things are
quote unquote better for the character to really
test them I don't think always I think it works
tremendously if it's done well I think always
would make story too formulaic and too predictable
so I think if it's done in a creative way where
we see the dilemma in a different light now
that the character has done the emotional work
through the action obstacle stake sequence and
at the climax you're at a place of did they
or didn't they come into the transformation
through the recognition of the flaw then yes so
looking at that does every protagonist need a goal
absolutely if there's one thing in story you just
nailed the most important thing in story the goal
is everything the the external goal as well as
the internal goal the understanding of the want
versus the need and the recognition that often the
character wants something externally that isn't in
the transformed thinking of the mindset things
that we talked about with the idea of survival
mindset intuitive mindset and intellectual mindset
so the goal is the goal is your if you don't know
what the character wants the story doesn't
work and knowing that is the character going
to get what they want externally or are they
going to get it internally is what keeps the
audience interested in the story do you ever say
to writers I feel like the goal for your character
the stakes need to be risen it's not it's not
not important enough but it's just it doesn't
seem like it would would be sensible for most
people all the time stakes is something the dream
is an aha moment that I had in my study of story
when you set the dream up at the beginning the
dream sets up the stakes when we know what the
character wants and why they want it through the
dream then we get a glimpse of the internal
and the external stakes so the dream is a
pivotal tool in the setup that can make all the
difference in the world with feeling the stakes
so is that something that you see sometimes with
new writers that their goal it's too small of a
goal you need to really like up the ante yes
and that goes into the idea of what a question
I ask all the time is what is the worst that can
happen if the goal is not achieved and that means
that if the answer is they could miss going on a
date or they could something so small that in the
bigger scheme of things doesn't feel like a life
and death type of scenario then it's not working
do you ever recommend people do like a Q & A with
their character yes I do in Story Therapy that's
interesting you ask that question excellent
question the in Story Therapy I have a whole
set of questions that I give writers that is the
idea of understanding the character's awareness of
what's holding them back of what happened in the
past of what do they want and getting to know your
character by having this type of interview with
your character and then two it seems like then the
characters would really come out more if you're
if you're doing this like interview yeah with your
character it seems like almost you would you would
it would become more and more real to you oh yeah
that I think the writer knowing the character
and feeling the character from the inside is
so important with how the audience
is going to experience the character
something I recognize that a lot of writers do
is they give the wound to the wrong character
so we'll end up knowing more about a supporting
character than we will about the central character
and when that happens then we're going what
do we know about the central character why
don't we feel the same type of poem we start
to go why isn't it the other character's story
since the other character has more to lose with
the stakes because we know their wound another
thing that I'm seeing a lot of stories do which
is fantastic is they are developing the wound for
the antagonist in more depth than they have and
as long as the protagonists we feel their wound
in at a high level and you parallel so you have
a strategy with the wound of the antagonist then
it can work really well is there a danger in the
writer identifying too much with the protagonist
because it's like too precious to them if
they if the lines are blurred and it's like
well essentially this is really me yeah is there
a danger in that yes because of exactly what you
might think when the character is too much like
them and they feel like I wouldn't do that yet
dramatically it doesn't work in the story and that
that has to do with like writers who are telling
story from an autobiographical angle versus an
angle of emotional truth when they're telling a
story from an autobiographical angle they get
stuck on the idea of well that didn't happen
well that didn't happen without recognizing
that life doesn't happen in dramatic structure.